mio padre fa 60 anni ho voluto portarlo
a vedere il concerto della sua band
preferita che sono i genesis che suonano
ad amsterdam al concerto a parte
amsterdam è una città che offre cosa in
post rare da vivere con il proprio padre
questo andava documentato nella maniera
più assoluta godete visto i due ragazzi
giorno più tanti auguri ma sai dov'è
cosa stiamo facendo no sai quanti anni
fa i quali si però non quelli lo sai in
che città stiamo andando londra l
apostrofo londra
[Applauso]
dimmi una cosa di cui sia orgoglioso di
me va dopo sette volte che sei stato
bocciato alla paziente non mi chiedere
niente
[Musica]
e ci è andata bene che siamo arrivati
perché nome della via non era proprio
semplice o
no sai cos'è questo tema
amsterdam è famosa per due cose se
indovini tutte e due le vinci una delle
due scelte le donne
questa è una all'altra tre donne va bene
vorrei evitare però visto che questo
video vede mamma io me lo a rischio di
ci appoggiamo ci da qualche parte che
adesso devo fare una cosa appoggiati qua
non ti piace tu stai qua e io arrivo
allo ragazzi quello del bulldog che è
uno dei più famosi se non il più famoso
coffee shop di amsterdam
sto per far provare a mio padre
un'esperienza mistica
tornato adesso proveremo una delle
specialità di questo post
una torta ma è un muffin questo a maggio
in particolare i fanno solo ad amsterdam
ha un sapore strano e questo cioccolato
qua però se tu lo provi non mangerai mai
più cioccolato normale tra sicuro prova
c'è anche l'altra cosa particolare di
amsterdam che fanno di solito i ragazzi
quando vengono qua che è fumare
ma riguardo perché queste sono cose
legali ok esistono anche altri modi di
assumere questo store fans ad esempio
con il muffin al cioccolato che hai
mangiato
c'era la droga dentro
[Musica]
ragazzi museo dell'erotismo forse una
delle poche cose che posso riprendere
qua foto per mamma è forse quella del
documento serio john lennon in che senso
no no no sei stato ottenuto
giocando una tempo siamo arrivati
finalmente questa è la piazza principale
di amsterdam noi a milano la conosciamo
benissimo perché abbiamo anche un detto
mica brasil molto opaco solo roba fresca
presa da me la cavo la foto con la morte
che tanto 60 anni manca poco vista la
simpatici mcdonald qua perché c'è
scritto luther dj
non so bene che cosa voglia dire però lo
so perché secondo degli scrittori luther
vi segue e citano in programma bacchieri
j passeri j e sto mary jane e già che ci
siamo perché non un bellissimo red e dj
plus arrendere dei plus a parte è anche
la base c'è la barca rete dj classi
niente da che abbiamo preso il rendering
ei plus
contento ti sembro scontento giorni
minchia redirigere ti dico una canzone
mela continui il povero gabbiano
si è spezzata una dog sono sotto la
scritta ad hoc scorre il reparto cani
dentro il menù rosa un po ipocriti
questa il negozio ufficiale dell'ajax
mio papà cosa incredibile della juventus
si ricorda benissimo delle pappine che
abbiamo preso dell'ajax voglio entrare
nei negozi dell'aio per carità adesso
c'è la il pezzo forte e va bene
chi son and with those novara in senso e
siamo usciti ragazzi quello lo stadio
dell'ajax tra l'altro anche i taxi ci ha
detto gentilmente follow the people e
noi forniamo the people hai capito
finalmente vai di mccarville juventus
vaio ma basta toglilo dai tuoi incubi va
definita abbiamo perso adesso pensa al
presente che è molto più roseo villareal
ecco qua il sole ti porto questi
concerti
zucchero
e uscita di lo spoiler ma meno rock dj
attenzione
quanto sei contento ti sembro scontento
giorni
a parte tutto ragazzini sono davvero
emozionato perché riuscire a portare il
proprio padre con le proprie forze a
vedere il concerto della sua band
preferita è stata tanta roba quindi
grazie anche a voi che avete reso
possibile tutto questo ragazzi
[Musica]
bello no grazie il regalo della mia vita
ha detto la seconda volta non stavo
registrando scusare dice quando uno si
ve le cose a [ __ ] a steve